when you were sitting next to charlemen
or brilliant idiots what happened
he said at which I I think it wasn't
really supposed to be funny but he said
um Kevin Durant reacted I posted him I
thought that [ __ ] was so soft but when
he was like um
yo I know yeah I just don't know if
Kanye is acting like a guy who I don't
know how long he might be around yeah
yeah four yeah and and you on a comedic
thing because I I see that in your eyes
you're like how long are we talking
yo yo everyone was just like yo yo Katie
was like this is nasty everybody was
just like yo yo show me why do you even
say this what's wrong with Charlemagne
[ __ ]
because they expect serious taste from
them all right that's fair but also
Charlemagne has said so much and I
always tell them this is you never
should say this but he said so much in
his in his life and he said
excuse me I don't tell jokes I'm not a
comedian
I don't tell jokes to tell the truth he
said that so much and I was like bro
stop saying that [ __ ] because you are a
comedian you do tell jokes and the last
thing you want is people taking these
jokes seriously seriously exactly but
with the KD [ __ ] that really annoyed me
it's like well Katie what you doing bro
that's what you're doing you commenting
are you going to call Kanye's people and
get them some help because if he does
end up God forbid dying
your little keyboard warrior [ __ ] didn't
help him maybe may you feel better about
you look good but you got actual power
people in your corner that you could
make phone calls too you know what I
mean also ask your business partner Rich
Kleinman the Jewish guy how he feels
about what Kanye said does he think
those are some nasty things KD why don't
you ask that guy who's made you a lot of
money doing them business deals does he
think those things that because I didn't
say you seeing I didn't say you saying
all the things that Kanye said was nasty
I'm just saying like I saw that little
comment which is wild [ __ ] by the way I
think like
I think he was just worried about Kanye
I took my wife to the season opener the
Nets and his bum ass loss and it's
embarrassing
I was on the floor I put my wife's feet
on
feet
floor seats I'm watching him say again I
don't pay the tickets at come on what
okay is the clout yeah
I mean Selena
yeah yeah yeah wait you in paper nah
shout out to see geek bro come on man oh
okay anyway listen damn all I'm trying
to say is all I'm trying to say is I
took her
and I'm saying to I'm saying to my wife
I'm like yo this this guy right here is
probably arguing Katie up not at all not
at all not at all so so uh his choice
though yeah Katie wanted to he's trying
to grab you up and you curved him no I
did not at all no I wouldn't do that I
was I was gassed and I was like this one
the greatest offensive players in
history damn and then they've got
[ __ ] their asses but we went to
Carbone for the second half there's a
Carbone inside uh the next really yeah
yeah inside Barclays but yeah but so
that was embarrassing for me as a person
you know that was some nasty [ __ ] he did
I'm not too sure embarrassing me I'm not
too sure like and I think he fell just
triggered by that video
so do something bro call somebody you
know who I think does that all the time
LeBron I think when LeBron said that
about
um LeBron annoy me Lebron said that
about that yeah no it did this is a
nasty conversation these guys are having
LeBron
tweeted
I don't know how to handle this
imagine typing that as a man with a big
ass hands holding your phone like a
tarantula hit my phone
a conversation is never happened
say what you feel bro come on man I'm
trying to get to the floor
you're trying to bring his team to the
floor you know
LeBron did the same thing what LeBron do
replying to Elon Musk when like there
was a tweet that went around and said
LeBron needs to reply to defense that's
what he need to do he need to reply okay
why are you not crazy
that's what you be on with the honey bro
yeah no no everybody drinks differently
yo obviously he gets a little drunk you
know me he started liking you know I
mean Chase with dicks I feel them just a
slice
[Applause]
[Music]
bro you like that video
went over the hill and like my tolerance
is there for that Community right for
welcoming uh the lgbtq dick move when
you were watching that video I think
that was that little ruffling we've seen
over there by you but um anyway